today i'm going to talk to you about
vision transformers since this is all
about transformers
um specifically their application for
visual representation burning but before
we jump into transformers i'm gonna
spend like 10 or 15 minutes giving you a
lot of context on all of this uh and
specifically also on the vision part of
things because i think a majority of
what you have seen and we'll see will be
about language
all right so let's get started my goal
and that of my close collaborators is to
find general visual representation and
you're going to soon see what that means
and why or what can we do if we imagine
we have a general visual representation
the hope is that with this we can really
kick start all kinds of tasks that
require visual input that means most
tasks that you do when you have your
eyes open basically
because if you have a good understanding
of what you see
then you can much quicker understand
what's going on and what you should do
um
and eventually i have now a little kid
and since the year and so i really want
that when he's grown up that there is
like some kind of robot
it doesn't need to be nice and pretty
like in movies just maybe an arm or
whatever
that my kid could teach or my parents
who cannot program can teach to do some
boring tasks that they really don't want
to do
and i believe one component of this is a
good visual representation that
generalizes to understanding the word
visually everywhere it's not all that's
required but it's one part and the part
that i'm trying to push
so this is for context and motivation on
working on general visual representation
and one good example of a general visual
representation is the humans
and i'm going to show you what i mean by
that so
here is a task that i give you there is
three classes class a b and c and they
give you five images of each class okay
um and here i give you a new image
and i'm sure that by now you all know
which class it is i'm not gonna ask
because i don't actually see you if i
was in the room i would do the raised
hands
uh but i'm sure you know it's class a
now
um okay this is fine we have seen
millions of flowers in our lives
hopefully uh but there is other kinds of
pictures like this uh satellite images
that you don't see much in your life
some people may have never seen it some
sometimes like when you fly or maybe on
tv or in the internet or so but it's
rather rare but still same story three
classes class abc five images of each
and i show you a new image this might be
a little bit less trivial than the
flower but i think i've spent enough
time talking that by now most of you
should know that this is class b
shows uh what is it basketball chord
right
all right now even more abstract you
don't see this in real life right but
still i give you images of class a and b
and just two to make it a bit easier
here because you need to use your brain
a little bit more
um
and i show you this new image
and now i should do a little bit of
smart talk to let you think and like you
see that there is like spheres boxes and
whatnot and by now i hope that most of
you know that this is class a
why because there is three objects in
class a and class b is always what is it
five objects
uh no matter what they are what they
look like
uh okay i think by now you more or less
understand what i mean when i mean a
good visual representation general
visual representation right some
some
i don't know how to call it in your
brain in your eyes
such that you can quickly
see something new and understand what's
going on with just a few examples
and then generalize from that
right and that's the goal then the next
step if we have the goal how do we
measure progress towards it
uh and this is a paper we did a few
years ago with my collaborators which
you call the visual task adaptation
benchmark it's kind of formalization of
the little game that we just played
so it's a benchmark
and there is some component that you or
anybody who participated in benchmark
does which is creating a model with some
data we don't really care what data what
mother how what not
just you come with the mother
then we come with this landscape of all
possible visual tasks that kind of make
sense
uh which is a big statement and we
sample some tasks from that
and this is kind of the task that you
have just seen they were actually
taken out of this task adaptation
benchmark and we have uh for our first
step made 19 such tasks where we try to
cover broad types of visual tasks
not just classes of natural images like
these docs and cats things but also of
very specialized images like satellite
image also non-classification tasks that
involve counting like the one i showed
you before right but that can be
expressed in this simple classification
api but that logically requires some
more thinking
um some things like distance we have
something with cars and with distance of
the closest car and things like that
um it should cover a broad range of
variation
and then
with the model that you came
to this benchmark you can do some
adaptation step on each of the data sets
one after another all at the same time
doesn't really matter but then you
should have as a result another
of this data set which is very small it
just has seen a few examples for each
class that then performs where there
and then we just take the average score
across all of these tasks and this is
what we call the beta task and this is
how for now we judge the
how
how good of a general visual
representation does your model and
adaptation algorithm have
and now just for some nomenclature this
preparation uh we have words that we
often use pre-training sometimes we call
it the upstream like upstream data
upstream training something so i may use
this word interchangeably with
pre-training and then there is the
second part which we usually call
transfer and then sometimes we say
downstream
uh and the adaptation for our in
principle is whatever you want but for
our work we almost always just use very
simple fine tuning without any bugs and
whiskers because it worked it's simple
and works well in general we try to do
things as simple as possible that still
work well and so sometimes i even just
say like fine tuning when fine tuning
that means moving from this pre-training
through the transfer
all right
so so far for the setting so far so good
good
then the question is how do we get there
and we spend a lot of time thinking
about this and trying different things
and this is also roughly the outline of
all that i have available to talk about
which doesn't mean we're gonna cover
everything
um
so i'm not gonna go like through the
outline exactly but you will see this
again and again and as you see vision
transformer the transformer only comes a
little bit later there's some stuff
before that
um
so this one just really quickly because
it doesn't matter for this course is
that we spent some time trying
self-supervised pre-training which is
very popular in language and envision
only recently has become popular and
it doesn't work that way like you don't
need to understand these bars but
basically higher is better and here
just look at the blue ones that's the
meetup score
for this future to meet up and search
supervised learning performs like this
bar we tried multiple methods and
multiple models and so on it's also
proper good benchmark but it was a
couple years ago
then we moved on to semi-supervised
training so a few labeled examples and a
ton of unlabeled examples that's this
next blue bar do you actually see the
mouse cursor sorry
uh we don't see the mouse cursor ah
maybe i need to do something
yeah okay
um yeah so then semi supervises that
blue bar which is a lot higher than this
other blue bar so what this means to us
is that by adding a few label examples
we are able to
get much better and or much more general
visual representation
then i'm not going to spend more time on
this and how exactly and so on
but i'm going to move to the next one
which was for us kind of a breakthrough
uh when we figured out that where if we
just
skate up fully supervised free training
then we get really much better
representations than everything we've
seen before and here i want to briefly
spend some time on that one because it's
the precursor to using vision or
transformers in video
so the idea is simple that
there are tons of images on the internet
and that's always what you hear is
motivation for self-supervisor
unsupervised learning right
but actually where these images come
from there is almost always some extra
information like surrounding the image
on the web or
if you collect it otherwise there's some
extra information there that you could
use as some weak source of information
or some weak labor right
then it happens that in google there is
some team that actually does this for
production um and they have collected
already a large data set with some
pipeline that from the surrounding
signals somewhat automatically but very
noisy annotates the images
and we wanted to figure out how how far
can we go when we scale up pre-training
then long story short you need a couple
ingredients one is patience i really
like this plot this is one of the curves
of just pre-training on large data with
large motors
doesn't the details don't really matter
the gist is that if i zoom into this
little box i see this here and this is
the metric for the training like the
performance in upstream that i see after
spending eight gpu weeks of compute what
does gpu it mean it means eight gpus for
a week or
sorry
one gpu for eight weeks or eight gpus
for one week
or 16 gpus for half week and so on right
but this looks bad reasonable person
would say yeah there's no progress for a
week on eight gpus this is what i'm
gonna stop and try something else but we
are not reasonable so we keep going
and this is what the exact same spot
looks like after a gpu month of training
uh and you can clearly see that things
are progressing right so it may not
always be obvious and you need patience
uh the second thing
is that you actually need to scale up
everything so this was work done with
resonance not yet with transformers as
you see a lot of resonant models here
the x-axis is the number of images
available in vision there is this image
in the data set which is a very common
uh super common data set for free
training which has 1.3 million images
there's another one which has 10 times
more images that stay public and then
there is one subset from this internal
group that has 300 million labeled
images
so
the y-axis is measure of accuracy on
some tasks and we tried many they all
look similar
and the dots are differently sized
resonates the blue dot is the standard
resonant 50 that everybody uses if this
one you train on more data it looks
promising at first but if you go to even
more data it looks like okay this
doesn't really seem that useful and this
is what most people have been doing for
a long time and
a lot of people even in google were like
yeah i tried this
internal checkpoint on this tons of data
it doesn't really have that much
however what we found out and in
hindsight is kind of obvious
uh is that you actually need to scale
not just the data but also the model
here this blue dot is a gigantic
resonance that is slow as hell but when
you scale this up together with the data
you keep getting benefit with adding
more data
and then if you do these two things
scale up everything and be patient
be patient but also be
quite scale of your patients
then you get a lot of benefits so here
there is a few shots transfer learning
what i showed you before
and
on the x-axis is size of the motor on
the y-axis is the accuracy on one of
these tasks but again others look
similar
and these three different curves are
retrained with different data set sizes
the green one being the standard one you
don't really see benefit or small
benefit from going with larger models
the blue one is 10 times larger you
start seeing some
slope upwards but really only with this
giant data you start like getting better
and better and better at these few
shortcuts for learning when you
pre-train online more data with larger
and larger models
second benefit that we did not
anticipate really at all but then found
out is that these models are super
robust when you scale everything up
this is object net it's a data set
that's specifically designed to measure
robustness and it shows things in crazy
like a chair in a bathtub and things
like that and you should recognize it as
chair
and here the pink dots are basically how
existing models and x-axis is again how
large is the model and pink dot is
existing ones from the literature and
then these lines same color coding is
what we found out and again you see this
large data and then going to large model
just gives you amazing benefits on like
in this case out of distribution
robustness
okay so this was like
amazing scale up everything be patient
and get huge benefits
uh sorry lucas
sorry for interrupting you but there is
a question from a student in the class
yeah right
do you want to unmute yourself and ask
it yourself
yeah i can i can ask my question uh can
people hear me maybe there's some
magazines on site once i can just step
away real quick yeah so the question i
want to know is what work has been done
characterizing the parameters after
pre-training finishes
like the reason why i'm motivating this
question is
it seems like we do this tremendous
amount of pre-training but it seems like
we might be able to significantly reduce
that if we just have smarter
initialization schemes
yeah you know i've been thinking this
for a long time actually also
um
and they've come to conclude that i
think
not
um i think there is like two parts one
is like what i like to call hand-wavy
the numerics of the weight you know that
everything is in a nice range such that
it can have nice
input output functions and so on and and
that your optimizer can do steps that
you know make reasonable change to the
input output function but not too large
and so on
i think that is part of it and that you
can get through good in it or good
normalizations and whatnot
but then i also think there is i do
think that these models memorize a lot
and then
personally i believe but i don't know of
evidence or so these models do more kind
of you know
remembering similarity to things they've
seen in training
and then as you grow things up they have
more memory and they have seen more
things so they should be better on more
newer things because there's more
similar things they have seen
and this i don't think you can like just
create one shot from initialization
but i don't have immediate
pointer to a paper at the top of my head
now to answer your question okay thank
you
i think we also have more questions so
has posted on the chat and
is
maybe in this order you want to ask your
question first
yeah for sure i could go ahead so i just
had a quick clarification on this this
uh
chart right here the the chart number
three
the bit l and bit and bit x are they the
same uh model architecture but just
trained on different data sets so the
bit ass is trained on the 1.3 million
all the way to the 300 million image
data set for bit l
uh yes and no the architecture is here
on the x-axis so within one vertical
slice these are the same architecture
and then the different points are random
restarts because when you're future
learning there is a lot of variance in
which few examples do you see and then
again this next vertical slice is the
same model and so on and as you go to
the right the model gets larger and so
you can see that for this little data
going to larger model doesn't really
help you much for free training only for
this giant data air means the giant data
not necessarily giant model in this case
right at least once
thank you
okay
uh do you have a question oh i see
you're raising your hand as well
hey yeah thanks um
what is the
intuition for the upstream performance
in figure 1 spiking so suddenly at
three points in in training
here right yeah
yeah yeah
again like around one point like i don't
know that just seems like a an
odd-looking uh training curve so like
yeah what's the uh intuition behind that
yeah this is uh old-school computer
vision thing or else what i mean a few
years ago uh is this when the learning
rate changes
in computer vision it used to be very
common to have the learning rate in a
kind of staircase pattern so it's
constant for a while and then you stop
you divide the learning rate by 10
usually boom smaller and then you
continue and this gives you this huge
jump and nowadays people don't use this
much anymore and this work was like
three years ago i think or two or three
years ago i don't remember
it was very common back then and
nowadays people use more continuously
changing learning rate schedule and then
you don't really have this sudden change
anymore but if you would overlaid it
would be like more continuously but
going roughly the same
and then in language i think most people
or many people use their just linearly
decreasing learning rate schedule where
also you don't see this effect because
learning rate continuously decreases
okay yeah sounds good
thanks and then this is what because you
asked for about this and this dotted
line actually here if if you're like
here you could say okay but this is
excessive right maybe it does really
seem almost flat maybe you could have
started the decay earlier and earlier
and earlier and then you would get the
same but much quicker and this is this
one shows what would happen then and you
do land at much worse place in the end
than with the patient
okay yeah yeah that makes sense
oh thanks
was there more question or i continue
i i think
both of you have your answers because i
i need to mention i don't see you i just
see
yeah it's fine we can coordinate that
lucas
um
hi yeah so i just want to make sure that
i'm like on the same page so basically
what you're trying to do is multitask
learning with convolutional neural
network slash lsts right that's kind of
like resnet
but you're doing multitask learning
correct no
where does the multitask come from or
why
because like initially like you showed
like different um
yeah okay
there is two phases the first one is the
training
uh and this pre-training
oh i didn't mention it yeah i just said
i don't care what you do in the
pre-training just pre-train somehow and
give me the mother and then i test it on
multiple tasks independently and
does means like transfer it to that task
which in our case means find unit just
on the task and see how well it does and
so on but it could mean other things
like later we moved to just learning a
linear regression on top of the
embeddings for each task
and now during the pre-training
what we do is just regular supervised
learning but just scaling everything up
and regular supervisor is just
well not in multitask but multi-label in
the sense that an image could have a
couple labels or not but it usually
doesn't have it this is a minor okay
you got it thanks
all right
uh yeah just have a quick follow-up
about the question rather than like the
discussion rallying uh
started about this uh it's like
ignorization or it's
memorizing the data in pre-training data
set so i know in the language side
there's a quite interesting phenomenon
that you can pre-train on a synthetic
language that's
uh it doesn't have any symmetric meaning
but they only have structural like you
know like paired premises or things like
that and that actually gives you almost
the same
boost in your downstream transfer as a
normal per training so uh i wonder if
say like so in
this means like in for language right
the structure seems to makes a lot of
contribution which can be replaced by
translation but i don't know if this
image is a different case maybe have
people done maybe some
synthetic uh pre-training this every
image
there was a paper i forgot the name and
the authors but it creates completely
synthetic images and like not even
rendering of some realistic things but
just completely
patterns waves and shapes and so on and
uses that for pre-training and then it
shows that they get almost the same
performance as image networking they
actually do this with vision
transformers
but
yeah they never go further or it's not
here you know they they kind of show
that you can almost get to this point
here
and then it's not clear how much further
can you go with it and i think probably
not much further
but it's just me guessing they're not
much for i don't have evidence for it
all right uh so i have one question and
then we can continue with the talk uh
sad that uh you think like the large
vision models are like learning some
sort of similarity
the data that they're trained on so do
you think that they are like behaving
like prototypical networks in a sense
they're behaving like what networks oh
so like prototypical networks
essentially like uh when you're like
doing like few short learning you just
say like i'm going to learn a network
space
probably not exactly but close-ish
i mean i cannot really say because this
is just some intuitive guess that i have
that's what they do but nobody really
knows what to do
right
um
yeah
i mean we do get much when we do
something like prototypical networks for
the future learning with these
pre-trained models we do get more worse
performance than when we do fine tuning
so there is a bit more to it
however i don't know
what is this more
okay thanks
all right let's continue
okay um
yeah so
all right and i didn't mention but like
on imagenet which is the top benchmark
in computer vision uh this with this
work with the big transfer we finally
were able to increase the score after
there was like a long period of a couple
years of no improvement but many
attempts that you see the greatest thing
this was yay awesome uh pre-training
scaling up everything and leveraging the
data
uh and then okay let's not care about
that
uh
yeah that's
okay this is just a little aside that if
we are in the setting that i mentioned
of pre-turning on huge amounts of data
and then testing on many other tasks you
should of course be careful that you
don't have images from the other tasks
in your pre-training data right
um otherwise you have seen them during
training and then you're not really
generalizing and you're just pulling
yourself with good scores
um and this is a real danger when we get
huge amounts of data because like
immediate images can totally be in huge
amounts of data right so we actually use
the
internal pipeline that is really good at
finding duplicates and also near
duplicates like when they are shifted
rotated squeezed color changed a bit
what not this it still finds it and we
use this to completely remove all images
from the test datasets that we test on
later and we actually found that a lot
of classic just vision data sets have
clear duplicates between their training
and validation set
between the training set of imagenet and
c bar 10 100 test sets and so on
uh so new duplicates are quite
widespread problem i envision and this
slide is just to say hey there are
problems but in all that we present we
actually took care of that in the
pre-training as best as we can we don't
have near-duplicates
um
right now back to
being like hey we figured out large data
a larger model and then things get
really good
um and that's how we got to transformers
basically in computer vision everything
was convolutional networks for many
years
uh and basically there was nothing else
in this key
however in language we saw a
transformation recently right that
everything used to be lstm everywhere
lstm was key and then came the
transformer and in the case when there
is a lot of data available suddenly
transformer worked much better than lstm
for little data that was still not the
case exactly um so what we then thought
is that okay
so we are now in this regime where we
have tons of data and we see benefit
from it can we see even more benefit if
we try also of the transformer
architecture in
vision
and that's basically what we did
uh to be fair there were a few other
attempts that try not transforming
vision before that i don't want to
detail too much here because i don't
want to like point fingers too much but
they were all not really using
transformers
for learning everything from the data it
was always like get
something out of a resonate first like
object detection proposals or high level
feature maps or things like that and
then stick a little transformer on top
but we wanted to go like all the way
just transformer everything
and so we came up with the simplest and
most natural i believe way of applying
transformers to vision which is you take
the image you cut it into pieces and
that's it like a puzzle uh
patches uh
and that's it each of these patches you
take it and you project it into your
embedding space which is the input to
the transformer embedding space is just
abstract space of let's say 768
dimensions for example how do you embed
it you just take the pixel values and
put the linear projector projection
layer on top so
take all the pixels flatten the vector
matrix multiply into whatever size you
want and use the same matrix for other
patches
um
and here we just went the simplest way
ever with non-overlapping patches and
everything you can and the people later
did go on and like
say hey this is almost a convolution
let's make proper convolution let's make
stack of them or not but this is our web
work later this is just the simplest way
to do it first
then we have these embedded patches and
we treat them exactly literally like the
word or the tokens in language and
then give them to exactly the birth
transformer from language voice and just
like in language we add this class token
or i think a language is like end of
sentence token or something
um
and we add the position embedding
embeddings to the tokens that can be
learned
and then we feed all of this to a
transformer encoder which has a mlp head
which reads out this class token
and then
maps it to softmax layer for
classification for example
and that's it that is the vision
transformer so it's literally you take
birth transformer but instead of
words or sentence tokens fit in patches
transform this into tokens and that's it
and then just same story as before scale
everything up compute data set model
size patients everything
and see what happens is this good or not
uh
that was the question
and now we can see a plot here this is
similar plot as before
the gray area is actually what were all
of the bit dots before
and now the bubbles are vision
transformers of different sizes
and the bubbler is kind of the size of
the model although it's a bit hard to
say exactly and what you can see first
is that with literal data image that is
the 1.3 million images
it works worse than resonance so if we
would not believe in this idea and just
try this right okay this is a crap idea
and 1.3 million images it's not that
later
then the 10 times larger data state
started like in the same ballpark as a
resonate and when we go to much larger
data with a much larger transformer then
we actually start out performing this
resume and we outperform it just by
later but this resonate was really hard
to get and is extremely clumsy and slow
and big
so we were very excited by this
um
now we did more controlled studies and
everything and one of them is like using
subset of the same data set and there is
lots of curves but basically just look
at the dark gray one and the light blue
one these are roughly similarly fast and
clumsy or
easy to use or difficult to use a bit
which is a resnet variant and with
division transformer and what you can
see vision transformer when we have
little in quotes little data is really
bad compared to resonance but as we
start having a lot of data actually it
starts out performing the resume and
this is very promising because i think
like everything that looks huge and a
lot and so on now in five or ten years
it's maybe regular like 10 years ago
imagenet this one seemed to be huge and
massive amount of data not anymore
so we should look to the future and this
looks promising for the future
then back to the same benchmark that was
another little jump
[Music]
in that order if you want to mute
yourself and ask the questions
sure yeah i think uh devil already
answered part of the question but i was
wondering in the input to the
transformer when you're chunking up the
image into uh little puzzle pieces and
then
um finding them does the order of
feeding these patches in matter like if
you switch the order
does the prediction maybe change
yeah that's a good question and i
actually have a slide on something like
this but not not exactly um
let me jump there so first of all if the
order is consistent
uh during training right and you you
don't shuffle the order again for each
new image then it's literally the exact
same you get the same curve same
everything because we don't encode the
order anyway if you start randomizing
the order all the time during training
then performance gets quite a lot of
words and let me show you why this is
the uh the slide was on my plan to
present anyways then if you ask about it
let's jump here these are this
visualization of the position embeddings
uh what does it mean so in this case we
had 14 by 14 patches that we cut the
image in so it means we have also 14 by
14
position embeddings although we just see
them as one long sequence of what is it
hundred
fifty something or i don't know already
something um
and now each of these pictures shows the
position embedding which corresponds to
this location
how similar is it to all the other
position embeddings so let's look at
this one for example yellow means
perfectly similar like exactly the same
and blue means opposite in terms of
cosine similarity
so this position embedding is most
similar to itself which is the pixel
here and then the neighboring pixels is
how similar is it to the position
embeddings that correspond originally to
the neighboring patch
and we do see a very clear pattern that
each position embedding is very similar
to the embedding from its surrounding
patches
and
we didn't implement any of this
all right we just had this position
embeddings at randomly initialized
variables and they are learned as freely
as the rest of the parameters of the
mother but they learn to recover this
notion of what are my neighbor patches
even though we don't give this
information anywhere at any time besides
the raw image data and the task to
please classify this image
um
so that's pretty cool i think but it
also means that if you take the trained
model now and give in
patches in a completely differently
shuffled order it's going to perform
poorly because this learned position and
values don't make sense anymore
we did try also to implement like
position embeddings which encode the
location as hard coded by us
um and
other fancy position embeddings like
relative ones
but basically none of that really
outperformed these freely learned and
then the three you learn this thing like
you just random image let it learn as
part of sgd and that's it and so we go
with that and suggest doing that
nice it's awesome
okay we have one more question from
hey yeah i was really good yeah this
slide um i think something that's really
interesting is we're talking about
scaling up the data and scaling the
moment
as well
but it seems like you're reaching and
passing joke right when you keep doing
this thing
so i'm curious if you have any thoughts
on that like is that or these points
just look like that or is there kind of
a
yeah i have another slide but much
further in the talk about that
um where i would like to not jump on it
if you don't mind and then maybe in
10-15 minutes we will be there
okay yes
um
yeah but maybe to be a bit optimistic it
does seem like the transformers have a
better slope here in the end and there
is next plateau earlier
sorry lucas i didn't mean did not mean
to interrupt
are there any questions before we
listen yeah can i ask my question real
quick sorry about that so what i'm
curious to know is
how does this vit compare to if you
equip a conv net so for example resnet
with an attention mechanism
like how much of this is due to the
structure of a transformer and the
particular way it operates versus just a
benefit of attention that a vanilla
confinet does not have access to
yeah so this is many this has been tried
many times before and the first time
that i know of was actually from
a mispronounced his name but
the inventor of resnet and some of his
colleagues they called it non-local
networks this was
i think even before the transformer
paper if i remember correctly
and they basically inserted attention
blocks at various locations in the
resonant and then they showed
improvement but it was like tiny
improvements that are it was a cool
block in the simple paper but it was not
really worth it and if people usually
place their attention
you can imagine if you place the
attention just on the pixels and don't
do this patch cutting this is way too
expensive computation right right if you
have two to four by two to four pixels
that's like
yeah i cannot do this in my head i don't
know 40 000 or so maybe pixels
attending 240 000 others that doesn't
work so people just do it in the very
high and very finer layers of the
resonance like
where it's maybe seven by seven and then
they add a bit of sprinkle a bit of
attention there but then you don't
really get much benefit of scaling
because it's essentially still a
resonant
and
there is in resonance there is this
block called squeeze excite that has
been getting really or has gotten really
popular and improves the resonance quite
a bit
and that is also kind of a form of
attention um but like nicely tailored to
images
and not really it's arguable
um but yeah it has been tried many times
before but it just it doesn't show or it
hasn't been shown to have this scaling
benefit as much as the bit
so i think i'm missing something
critical here which is you just said
contract or it's computationally
difficult
attentionally at a low level in the res
net but why is it any different than
doing an attention layer in the vision
transformer
because we we cut the patches first so
we have maybe 14 by 14 patches which is
not that much
okay
but i'm confused like
you could imagine not at a high level
not at a high layer in the resonant but
at a relatively good layer after you've
applied like one or two convolutional
filters
to uh convolutional layers excuse me
then you have something
besides the patches
uh that's still 50 by 50 at the early
layers and that's but 50 by 50 is
significantly less than i don't know
like 400 by 400 or whatever
but it's still 2 500 tokens attending 2
2 500 tokens which yeah i mean it's a
lot but it's not
comparable
i don't know okay cool thank you yeah i
mean it could be tried okay maybe
another answer to your question is then
we're slowly getting to this my next
slide
after the set of questions um
where we do try something almost like
what you said um have a very small part
of the resonant and then stick
a
transformer on top of it but like the
full transformer encoder on top of it
and not just sprinkle a few attention
layers and then continue with and so on
and this is this process
and we call them hybrid but that's
almost literally what you said actually
like a few early layers from the
resonance and with different varying
amount and then stick it therefore
transforming quarter
and this
seems to work right too especially for
the
uh when you exactly in this case is
amount of compute so for the little
compute it seems to work well but then
the scaling behavior of the pure
resonate is a little better so we
focused on that i think we later tried
also hybrid further to the right and it
was a bit lower but it was after the
paper so it's not on this plot which i
just cut out of the paper but you can
already see the trend here
yeah so if you don't scale all the way
up then this is a totally reasonable
thing to do have a little bit of
resonance and then that the encoder from
transformer
do you want to ask your question
uh yeah i was uh just wondering about
the
um basically there's like a like a short
section in the paper about like fine
tuning and like higher resolution and in
that case right like the pre-trained
like position invaded embeddings sorry
um
are like uh skewed right and then it
basically says that you guys are like
interpolating can you like talk like a
little bit like how do you interpolate
what's going on yeah actually when when
i checked the slides earlier today i was
like ah we could have a slide on that
and we don't have a nice visualization
in the paper either because it's a bit
difficult to explain but this is the
best starting
point we have so if you want to increase
the resolution of the image
means and you keep the patch size fixed
it means you have more patches suddenly
right and then as you say the fashion
embeddings like how what do you even use
as
position embeddings right
um
and basically you can see here that we
see that they learn a very regular
structure right we don't really know
what is the structure of this position
embedding the color we just see the
similarity to each other and that it is
very very regular
and so this gave us the intuition that
we may be able to just take them
um kind of imagine these boxes they
slide apart and new boxes appear between
them and they are just the interpolation
of the surrounding ones
and that's basically what we do with the
position and paddings
we create new ones where there are
missing ones because we need more
um
and by interpolating the surrounding or
more precisely we basically see them as
a picture in this case 14 by 14 with 700
something channels or whatever is the
dimensionality and then we basically
resize this like you would resize a
picture by by linear interpolation
and that way we get more and new
position embeddings that we don't
understand where they are but they
follow the same pattern as the learned
ones just as
at a higher resolution basically
yeah
there were
quite a few words they tried varying
other things um one that i especially
liked recently it's called early
convolutions hair transformers c better
or something like that and they
basically say okay instead of this
linear projection instead of this one
big linear projection we replace it by a
stack of three by three convolution with
a stride two
uh and then they have also
non-linearities between the
normalizations between them
but such that the overall stride is the
same as the patch the this petrify so
the
outcome will then be the same
dimensionality as after this patch
cutting and then projecting and then
they show that
it
supposedly it makes it a bit easier to
optimize in the sense that more
optimizer settings are good settings
um
in many scenarios it performs the same
but like more robustly to get there
and they also show some scenarios where
this performs much better
uh like for example when pre-training on
actually when they pretend on more data
that seems to perform even better
um
i have played a bit with it and tried to
reproduce it i don't have it fully
reproduce it but i don't see as much
benefit as in the paper yet
but that's not to say that the paper is
wrong just that i didn't get there yet
um
that is one example of them there are
other papers that do stuff but this one
i found especially interesting because
it's simple
thank you
all right
continue we don't have any more
questions
all right then let's see yeah i have
like three more interesting details from
the paper and then
depending on if you want more discussion
or more content i have more content like
also the question about does it saturate
here or not um
all right so another interesting thing
that we had in the paper but it is
buried in the appendix um
and then
follow-up papers from others have been
written on this by now actually is like
how should we scale these transformers
right in the
high level shape of the transformer
there's lots of settings that you could
choose um and we actually tried many of
them so we started with the like
reasonable medium size transformer it is
not in the middle and then we vary
things one by one
such that we always double the compute
so for example this pink line if we go
to the right this point
increases the width
such that we double the compute
x axis is compute
relative to this starting point and we
have all of these different settings
there's the width which is the how wide
is are the vectors with which say
attention is done which is for the base
model 768 and then it goes larger or
smaller
um
that is like meh as you see scaling this
does not seem promising so we didn't
scale that much
uh then there's other things like the
width of the multi-layer perceptron and
or some people call it the one-by-one
convolution in these attentions and this
seems to scale a bit nicer this orange
part i actually wonder where it went to
the left i don't remember
i don't know if it's hidden somewhere or
if you just didn't scale it down but
anyways then another thing to scale
which does not exist in the transformers
from text is the patch size as you make
the patch smaller you get more and more
tokens out of an image
and thus more and more compute capacity
um
this is the green one which also seems
to scale nicely
um
then the depth is an interesting one
this yellow one and this is the number
of encoder blocks
as we scale it first seems like wow this
is the thing you want to escape but then
it does seem to plateau and it scales
really badly if you decrease the depth
so that's not a good thing to decrease
however the width seems to be a good
thing to decrease if you want to go to
smaller models and then the blue is just
scaling everything together such that
the compute is kept like everything by
roughly the same one that seems to scale
nicely as well as the rest and this is
relatively simple or at least
conceptually so we like this so we went
with that whenever we scale up or down
the model
um
and this i one i really like is the
inference speed because if you have the
image size of two to four pixels it
actually means you have two two four
bytes to do four pixels right so if you
have uh let's then you petrify it with a
16 by 16 patch for example patch size
then you have
14 by 14 patches so that's the sequence
length is actually 150 right and then
on top of the sequence length you have
the set attention operation which is
square again so overall with the image
with respect to image size the
self-attention operation is uh to the
fourth power what's it called
quartic
um
so that is really bad like everybody who
sees oh of something to the fourth is
like what the hell are you doing this is
never gonna escape
um so we checked what does it look like
in practice with the image sizes that we
operate in and this is what you see here
on the y-axis is the
how fast it goes basically how fast it
does inference and on the x-axis is
varying the input size
and
this
what this means it doesn't look so bad
yet
basically when you go here to the 512 to
the real argument then you see that the
transformers actually start going down a
lot more than the
resonance
but in this reasonable image size let's
call it a typical it doesn't seem so bad
in practice yet so we're not getting hit
by the very big o
but as we go larger it will likely be a
problem and there have been a lot of
follow-up works trying to make that
better right
um
right
then
this is the last one from the original
bit paper um this is looking at the
inputs receptive field size so in the
self attention operation
how far ago
do heads typically attend
and here on the x-axis we see the layer
in the network to the right is more
towards the output the classes and to
the left is more towards the input the
patches
and the y-axis is how far on average
across i think the whole validation set
does the self attention look and does
look means that the peak of the set
attention or the max how far is it away
something like that
um
and each dot is a different head because
we can use multi head safe
self-attention right
and so what this shows is that in the
early layers actually you have some
heads that go look far but also a lot of
heads that look very nearby them so
locally and as we go deeper in the model
we only are left with heads that on
average look further
so
it's just some kind of analysis there is
not immediately action to take about
this but it's interesting to see that
earlier layers
they learn a mixture of looking
to a local neighborhood and looking
globally and later layers only look
globally
right
so that is about the original
vision transformers
um
no
i don't know how long we want me to
continue speaking or discussing i have a
couple of options that i can talk about
which is one project that was further
scaling up bits and this one also has
the answer to the i can also jump
straight to the answer if you don't want
to hear the rest but to the question of
like what's how does it continue to the
right are we separating
um
there is another project about how to
train vision transformers when you don't
have massive amounts of data can you
still do it is it reasonable or is it
maybe just unreasonable to do
uh this one is maybe too unrelated let's
not talk about this and
the last one is like i talk all about
these benefits of
a really large model when you pre-train
them on lots of data okay that's nice
that's how we get a good model
but then actually using a model that is
massive is not fun at all like it
doesn't fit on your gpu you need like
multiple tp used to even use it so
people are not happy to use it and
usually still go back to smallish models
even though they know like larger models
should be better what can we do about it
that's another project we had which is
about distillation
so
i would say it's up to you guys what you
prefer to do or if you have plenty of
questions we can continue with the
questions now because i think now the
original one hour would be over
right
right
i think one suggestion was like we can
continue the talk
and uh we will also be recording it so
people like you can like just like go
and see it if they miss out something
uh so we could do that
yeah the other thing is two people have
their hands raised so we can um okay
questions first
up to you guys and fight right away
um
so
you guys want to ask a question
yeah i just had a pretty basic question
um so if an object lies on the border
between the patches
um does that impact the model's
performance in any way
yeah i mean that's not a basic question
it's a good question
there is a mix of answers
so one is we didn't specifically go and
test this it would be an interesting
thing to test in a very controlled way
with some of the trained models um
that's for sure
um
the other thing is that
when you have a massive data set like
300 million images it's an insane amount
i used to try to conceptualize how much
is imagenet one million images and i
think i did the math is like if you go
through an image and look oh look at all
of the images each image for a couple of
seconds you were sitting there for a
month or something like that don't
remember
but so 300 million is just insanely
massive and then on top of that we do
actually use random augmentations like
random crop out of the image
so i would say it's the default that you
see objects that don't fall on a patch
um during the training already
and if you look at here basically this
is the standard model like how the
patches are when we have 14 14x40 they
look roughly this size also
um
then
an object is usually scattered across
many patches actually
because objects in typical images are
relatively large right people don't take
a picture where the object of interest
is super tiny in the corner
uh so that's the default that you see
during pre-training and so i believe
that the model just learns to do that
much better actually
then the
other answer to the question is like
okay maybe if you did some nicer thing
than this very crude patch cutting like
for example this converse stack of
convolutions that i mentioned maybe this
is even better
um
thank you
all right yeah uh so you mentioned that
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
the audio was not that good but i
believe i understood the question is
that we say that transformer lack
locality uh
bias or prior or whatever and why is
this even something that we want right
uh wouldn't we want our mothers to know
about locality if they are about
pictures in the first place
um
yes and no
uh so this that's why i gave the context
in the beginning this is all about what
happens when you scale things up
and
specifically what
in ideal world at least in our mind
we want
gigantic amounts of data and we believe
that it will just keep growing as the
years go by and there will be more and
more data
uh just generally there
and then we want the model to have as
little of
our thinking built in
because what we may think that is good
to solve the task may actually not be
best to solve the task you know maybe
like uh
analogy would be like
uh what was it alphago that made some
moves that experts would say this is
crazy this is a silly move but it
actually then was much better
uh and in the similar way we want to
encode as little as possible into the
model such that if we just throw massive
amounts of data in the difficult task at
it that we might think things that are
even better that we didn't think of
before
this is our approach because we believe
that like as i mentioned i think
already uh what seems massive and
excessive now will be the norm in five
years or so so that's where we want to
go and look what's the direction
however
uh if you want to like just get
something working now and don't have
massive amounts of data and don't want
to use pre-trained mother for some
reason which
always use a preaching mother
but if you don't want to uh then it
makes total sense to bring in some of
your prior intuition and knowledge of
what should probably help the mother
like locality
[Music]
[Music]
like isn't that sort of
like yeah i don't know
maybe i'm not seeing like
exactly why we do not want those
investments but
you may be elaborate on that why why is
it that we don't want
um like locality or what translation
well ideally we want the mother
that is powerful enough to
learn about this concept itself if it is
useful to solve the task
if it's not useful to solve the task
then
if we hardcode it in there is no way for
the mother not to do this right
that is ideally the outcome and in a
similar way also that in language you
know it seems to be
nonsense to not encode the from left to
right direction of text like in rmns but
then comes transformer and just doesn't
and works much better if you throw a lot
of data at it and it recovers that
plus some more or more flexible variant
of it or something like that that is
even better for serving tasks
so basically the idea being that
we are not as smart to design the thing
the model in the way that will be best
for the task let's rather give it all
the flexibility and all the data needs
to figure out what is the best way of
solving the task
i really this is a philosophy of
approaching it i'm not saying that is
the only true way right
okay uh so we have around seven minutes
left before the scheduled end of the
talk
and lucas we want to be mindful of your
time as well because it's it is evening
where you are
so
one thing we could do is you could i
don't see any more questions right now
so you could quickly sort of go over
the last
maybe skipping through the the details
and just talking about
the final results
i will do these two in the high level
then those two that are still very very
tight to transformers and also some
questions that happened before
like the first question was like okay
are we saturating yes or no
and
here
no
uh this was the width
on this benchmark from the original
transforming paper but then it's like
these transformers when we use them we
just notice they have really nice
scaling properties and they seem
actually to be easier to scale up
without paying massive compute as much
as resonance
just from that feeling from us having
experience with both and so we went and
looked what happens if we
scale vision transformer just as far up
as we possibly can
and we spend quite a lot of our blood
into making this happen
one part of it is scaling the data set
so we went back to this google internal
team that this 300 million data set is
just one out of many that they work with
and we asked the round and they
basically had the three billion like ten
times larger data set that we could also
like play around with so there we go we
want to scale up the data set
and
it's just showing yes just scaling up
the data set and switching it gives you
benefits but that's not all of it then
the next thing is we needed to figure
out how to use less memory on device
like on gpu or tpu
because already previously with this
score we fitted the model as much as we
could click so we did a lot of tricks
that i will skip for now and are able to
stay much larger this is like
this plot shows the size of the model in
the different shape factors that i
mentioned before like the width of the
mrp on x-axis the surf attention width
on the y-axis and then the different
plots are different layers for the depth
these blocks are how much how large a
transformer we did in the original paper
and then boom one step further and two
steps further this is just super massive
transformer we did in this uh scaling
uh paper and with all of our tricks from
how much larger we could go a lot louder
um then yeah some learning rate stuff
and it is really cool i recommend people
to look at square with learning rate
schedule which is cool and often just
mentioned as a side note
it is also cool but i'm gonna skip it
for the interest
and basic interest of time and
basically we scale it up a lot and of
course again we get uh always this
envision imagenet uh number a bit higher
this is actually plus two percent on
what we had before which is very
significant in this high percentage
range there
but also what's very interesting is the
flu shot again
uh by just keep scaling up everything we
get
super large boost in fuel shot again
this is imagenet top 1 accuracy and for
example it's just 10 images per imagine
a class
which means 10 000 images flatter
because thousand classes we get this
big of a drop we get 85 percent of one
accuracy which is what
uh what is what you typically get when
using the full data set basically
um so this is
the gaping up makes actually a few shots
work significantly better and then i'm
gonna skip on this well this actually
has an interesting message this is
three times the same story but measured
in a slightly different way which is
that
if you make the model larger it actually
needs to see fewer images to get to a
similar score like this
blue line is a tiny vision transformer
and the base vision transformer in the
large one and the y-axis is the arrow so
lower is better and actually you need to
see
still we're talking in millions of
images and here's 100 million images but
still you need to see a lot fewer images
with the larger models doesn't mean a
lot less compute right because the model
is larger and the slower
but that's interesting
and then there's some scaling laws that
are popular in language and we i think
maybe for the first time in
discriminative uh image learning show
that yeah they
appear to be here too
um and
then
right then we want to
sorry i had the order of the slide mixed
up in my head i'm a bit surprised but
then another thread was that besides
further scaling up the model we wanted
to push even further into this direction
of
less hand engineering
of things into the model architecture
and then with the
vision transformer transformer in
general what is the obviously most hand
engineered part of it is the search
attention so we try to what can we do
something like more generic than that
and
less smart than that basically and we
ended up by replacing it essentially
with just a multi-layer perceptron
that however
has a little bit of structure but much
less than self-attention so they will
skip the structure
for the sake of time and we're coming
back to this plot where the question was
aren't we saturating now this plot is
slightly different we again have this
bit resonate here in black and the full
green line is the vision transformer and
the other color also the full lines are
the vision transformers right these
exactly same numbers as from before
however now we also throw in this mixer
architecture which we believe is even
more flexible and less hand in
engineering transfer and as you see with
less data it's even worse
uh however with much more data it may be
surpassing the transformer or it may be
random noise uh
not clear at this point right because
it's the only point where this happens
so we need to go further so we use this
three billion data set for example from
the previous paper
that i mentioned here and try to extend
these lines to the right to see what
happens we don't extend many of them
because these are very expensive
experiments that require a ton of
patience but we extended two most
interesting and it seems that it
continues and that
first of all yes the vision transformer
keeps
increasing we don't have such experiment
with the resonate because it doesn't
look promising enough to pay the cost of
doing it
but it also seems that the mixer the
what we believe is even more flexible
architecture actually is
consistently above the transformer now
which is good news
and
yeah with this good news so we're now
right at the
time when i should stop right or open
two more questions again
yeah uh i guess as a question
that's the follow-up on the scaling that
you showed earlier it's really into my
question
i'm curious how this model size compares
to the model sizes for earth or like the
natural language
like especially going from like smaller
models to much bigger models but
never they comparable at all in terms of
model size and if not like why do you
think
what is there for the models for these
two different classes
yeah actually a colleague of mine has a
slide which i hate but he loves it's the
model number of parameters in nlp and in
vision
and the question is how do you measure
your mother's side
if you just measure number of parameters
then these visual models are much
smaller
however
the language models number of parameters
like a huge chunk of it is in the
dictionary for example which for us just
doesn't exist it is linear embedding
which is trivial number of parameters
um
so in terms of number of parameters it's
much smaller
my personal opinion is number of
parameters doesn't mean that much
then the other way that you could
measure is maybe in terms of compute
like how much floating point operations
does it do on one data point and in
terms of this
uh it's in the same ballpark however
last time i checked which is quite a few
months ago
the largest language model was still
like four times more or five times more
in vision model i believe
um
yeah so that's the two ways of measuring
model size i don't think either of the
ways is the one true way to measure
model size and i think it's actually an
interesting research topic like how to
properly measure and like order models
in terms of capacity it's not clear
do you know why the vision is sorry the
vision is smaller
i think it's just there is less interest
in it
and so less resources spent on it
basically
um like in google there are many more
many many more groups doing research
with language than with vision
and i think we are one of the few groups
that have access to a lot of resources
and are interested in scaling up things
in vision so much whereas in language it
seems there are a lot of groups that are
doing that
i think that's the main reason actually
it's not that we don't want to go beyond
that or
like
if we can we would go even more
awesome thinking
right so we are actually over time at
this point so anyone who has to leave
please feel free to do so i think before
we do that uh lucas thank you so much
for joining
for all the way from
across the ocean and we know it's it's
in the evening so thank you for taking
your free time to come and talk to us
here
yeah thanks for an invitation always
like to talk about the work